justin bruhl goes for the dodgers 24
year old left-hander undrafted free
agent in 2017. sign with the dodgers
worked his way up
colin moran the first baseman he had
played third base
plays some first base left-handed hitter
276 batter
max muncie playing out in short right
field a few steps
and a bouncer right to pujols he grabs
the high hop
walks over to first and steps on it
and retires colin moran terrific play
by albert pujols
so the pirates are done on the top of
the first no runs one hit one left no
dodger errors half inning in the books
it's the pirates nothing and the dodgers
coming to bed steven brought goes for
the pirates 29 year old left-hander out
of san diego in his sixth season in the
big leagues he's pitched a lot of the
bullpen because of a lat strain in his
arm and here's albert pujols
but if you go away he'll drive it to
right 3-2 is rolled over to third hayes
on the second one castro plenty of time
double play
they go around the horn five four three
and add that to the record welcome to
the major leagues for andre jackson a 25
year old from
tinyville arizona
town of about ten thousand outside
tucson
polanco aboard
stallings in scoring position at second
base and rodolfo castro the second
baseman number eight hit her up
comes back getting and andre jackson has
his first career major league strikeout
his dad tim his mom choch cheering him
on
some good movement on that change-up
broad is a very good hitter
259 with a home run in his major league
career at the plate
like jackson brought was a two-way
player in college
no score two on two out two ball one
strike pitch to the pittsburgh pitcher
stephen brault
and he swings and he bounces it towards
second max muncie gloves it straightens
up throws onto first and andre jackson
and his first major league inning hangs
at zero
for the pirates in the second
no runs one hit to left no dodger errors
to the bottom of the second we go at
dodgers stadium it's the dodgers nothing
pirates nothing
justin turner will lead things off
here's the one two swinging a miss
brault strikes about with a fastball one
out
here's aj pollock
ground ball
throw and he got him
he brian hayes
robs pollock
taylor's another guy that really
you know the dodgers
brought in in just a minor deal he was
not amounting to much with seattle
here's the pitch swinging a miss struck
him out
brock came down and in on taylor off
speed and struck him out so two
strikeouts in the inning for stephen
bralt we'll move it to the third pirates
nothing dodgers
at first one away here's reynolds
fly to right to in the first inning
cracks is bad and a flare of a base hit
to right hayes headed for third mckinney
comes up gunning high throw pulled down
he's
outfield assist for mckinney and a great
leaping catch by turner to put the tag
down
two outs reynolds at second base colin
moran the first baseman to hit her
jackson set at the belt looks back at
second base comes home swinging a miss
strike three fired another fastball pass
moran
two strikeouts in the inning for andre
jackson gives up a hit
and the pirates leave a man through two
and a half at dodger stadium it's the
dodgers nothing pirates nothing andre
jackson will get the bet
the dodgers pitcher
remember he was a college outfielder you
know he's going to get the slider
and he struck him out looking
and that ends the inning tigers go down
one two three brawl pitching wonderfully
through the first three of course pujols
hit into the inning ending double play
in the first inning
the pitch and a wave and a miss brawl
picked him apart struck him out with a
fastball
come to chase a little bit there yeah up
and away too which is unusual for elvis
pirates now have two on two out but
their best hitter is coming to the plate
and brian reynolds
reynolds one for two tonight he's
singled in the third and then went to
second on the throw back in the first he
fly to mckinney and right
stretch checks the runners now they go
payoff pitch swung on hit deep to right
field but playable
and mckinney back underneath it in front
of the track makes the catch
and the side retired changeup
the cambio has been
sensational
for andre jackson tonight
nothing across for pittsburgh two left
middle of the fifth dodgers nothing
pirates nothing
barnes the number eight hitter
ready better against the lefty brawl
broad ready and the pitch swinging a
bouncer back to the mountain he almost
left too soon he'll flip it on to first
for the final out and the inning is
through through five from dodger stadium
no score
and muncie up with one out and a runner
in scoring position pitch
and it hits him muncie's plunked
throws his bat down he's not too happy
about it he got hit right in the back
pollock hit a sharp ground ball that
hayes made a terrific play on right up
the line
back in the second bounced out routinely
to shortstop in the fifth we're in the
sixth base is full of dodgers in this
scoreless game
two are away mirrors on in relief of
brawl base is loaded two outs the pitch
swinging a bouncer up the middle and
there's park who'll shovel it onto
castro for the force
and they get out of it
so double a hit batter and a walk three
left for la the seventh coming up no
score scoreless game in the seventh
polanco castro and then a pinch hitter
here in the inning against grottorol the
pitch near shoot tops
and it hit him yep he's aboard polanco
hit by pitch
where dolph castro will bat against
squadron
and the pitch is swinging the ground
ball to short and turner was trying to
cover second he couldn't get back to his
right and everyone's gonna be safe
no the shortstop was the man covering
second and he broke toward the bag and
couldn't break back
with second there's nobody out wilmer
defoe 11 pinch hits this year gets the
at bat here against grottoral
the pitch bonnet perfect
and toward ballinger he'll join yes awry
and it goes into right field polanco is
in to score and the pirates take a
one-nothing lead here in the seventh
and moran steps to the plate no for
three tonight
one for his last 12.
first pitch to moran swung on ground
ball to first
grabbed by bellinger he steps on the bag
and blake trinen
extinguishes the fire immediately after
coming out of the bullpen with just one
pitch
it is stretch time at dodger stadium
middle of the seventh inning
the pirates one dodgers nothing
billy mckinney is all for two
one nothing game seventh inning here
mckinney on one one hits a high drive
and his first dodger home run ties the
game
really with his first home run since
june 28th when he was in a mets uniform
well what a night for billy mckinney
as he brings better than 48 000 to their
feet at dodger stadium
muncie looking for his first hit
there it goes
maxwell swinging the silver hammer gives
the dodgers a 2-1 lead
max muncie
wow
home run number 26 for muncie
justin turner
would like nothing more than to add a
little insurance
gets to turner hits him
and the franchise leader and hit by
pitches gets hit another time well
tsutugo
who side with the pirates today
lefty batter who
was once a
home run champ in japan and the o2
swinging a line drive to laugh this
one's down for a hit into the corner
sosugo around first he's heading into
second and his first pirate at bat yoshi
with a double
and it's the fabulous rookie
the future for the pirates key brian
hayes who has reached three times
tonight
punch to first muncie's got it takes it
to the bag and the dodgers win it 2-1
you